poi risponde inizia il prossimo video
tenendo in bocca tre cucchiaini di
nutella per poi dire in pendant tutti
ragazzi minuti a questo nuovi dove sono
fa vj e sbucciate per farglielo leggere
a fare che a questo è difficile ci provo
c'è un giro all'inferno per terra ed a
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fuori j
ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog come
solito ragazzi direi ricominciare con la
farà più della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da bene che tra
ragazzi si chiama così perché nella
firma ha scritto solo vane quindi io
dico bene previtali pelle meglio non
specificare va bene così comunque
ragazzi ci teneva a precisare che
praticamente tutte le fanatiche mi avete
mandato
sin da quando ho aperto il canale voi
non lo sapete ma io le tengo tutte
quante sono nella mia cartella volevo
annunciare ke siamo arrivati a quota
mille fan art previti sono talmente
tante che potrei fast armi la giornata a
spogliarmi le tutte senza senza finirle
perché sono troppe comunque ragazzi
veramente grazie di cuore per tutti i
disegni che mi avete pagato perché sono
uno più bello dell'altro veramente con
che reca passando alle news se sono
stato ospite a radio m2o ed è stata
un'esperienza veramente fantastica che
non mi sarei mai immaginato di finire in
una radio prima o poi veramente è stato
meraviglioso con che la fine nonostante
la tensione andato tutto per il meglio e
quindi l'importante è questa la fine ci
siamo divertiti e quindi va bene come
altra cosa ragazzi volevo darvi una news
particolare che ancora non avevo fatto
una cosa del genere che farò in futuro
ma non in un futuro tanto lontano
abbastanza presto o di fare un contest
dal primo contest che facile con i
vincitori riceveranno la maglietta come
quella maglietta analitico le magliette
che indosso io aveva in mente di far
vincere i fan più attivi ovvero quelli
che condividono di più i video che
mettono più mi piace c'è insomma alla
fine abbiamo io posso vedere la lista di
chi è più attivo sul canale ciò che c'è
una funzione di youtube che permette di
vederlo e melo sapere comunque ragazzi
così almeno mi faccio un paio di idee su
come la pensate poi e vediamo se
riusciamo a far qualcosa comunque
ragazzi molti di voi mi hanno chiesto di
continuare eve che sperimenti avevo
finito prima delle vacanze di natale
propria mente ed ho scoperto che aveva
dieci finali più o meno farò gli altri
dieci piani state tranquilli perché mi
state chiedendo tutti
ed e volontari tutti serve quindi mi ci
vuole un infinità di tempo ma tranquilli
che lo faccio c'è solo questione di
tempo poi tranquilli la cosa che volevo
dire che tra poco usciranno un casino di
di serie nuove tipo horror usciranno
occasioni videogiochi horror anche nonno
horror comunque anche divertenti
comunque ne usciranno una marea e quindi
non vi preoccupate perché di serie ce ne
saranno un casino e ci teneva a dirvelo
perché ultimamente mi state
tempestandoli domande del tipo favi
quelle che inizia una serie horror coi
contro maroni tranquilli che arrivano
fondi preoccupate è detto questo ragazzi
dire che possiamo passare allo scarto
dei pacchi e di siamo ragazzi per questo
blog ho deciso di aprirne 3 per
riaprirle 2 sull diciamo voleva offrirne
3 in più volevo anche aprire questo qui
che non ho capito che cazzo è però
sembra facile da aprire è per me già
vuol dire tanto è quindi ragazzi direi
di iniziare con il più piccolo che è
questo qui su una forma parecchio strano
c'è scritto merli crismas anche se
l'offerta un po in ritardo scusami è
mica la weight american nightmare
grazie mille all'espansione di alan wake
me questa non l'ho giocata e mi chiedono
altro magari la faccia non lo so
comunque grazie mille
e fantastico il regalo di natale l'ho
aperto la siamo a metà gennaio ma vabbé
non importa grazie infinite davvero e ma
l'importante alla fine è che tu menti ma
voi ragazzi facciamo finta di niente
passiamo al secondo pacco con un po più
grande mi piace non si paghi perché sono
facili da aprile è questa ragazza è già
un pregio perché ci metto sempre casino
ad aprire i pacchi da dove cazzo si apre
non di quella mondo se la scatola è
bellissima ma la tengo per fare i finti
canditi e c'è un biglietto ciò fa di
tutto è iniziato la scorsa è stato mio
amico vi consiglio alto video su youtube
da quel momento si è diventato la mia
passione
i ragazzi consigliate famiglie ai vostri
amici e diventerò la loro passione
grazie mille comunque continua così favi
e vedrai che insieme ai tuoi 200mila
iscritti è un pò vecchio su fatto
raggiungeremo traguardi strepitosi sia
avevi ragione comunque grazie di tutto
fa vps primo piano il fatto che è
delicato grazie mille sei gentilissimo
non ho idea di che diavolo sia ma so già
che sarà la cosa più epica che abbia mai
visto
ditemi che non è fottutamente vero un
orologio fa vj tv con tutti i personaggi
minchia la cosa è strepitosa cioè mesi a
scriver not outlast c'è anche che mario
perfetto se anche la batteria in omaggio
quindi a fantastico e vediamo se sto
farlo partire così subito subito perché
non lo settato tipo musoma le news e
parte la mia vita è fottutamente
completa comunque flavio ti ringrazio di
cuore per l'orologio meraviglioso e
direi di passare al terzo è penultimo
pacco perché poi c'è ancora cosino ad
aprire questo questo è assurdo ma non
c'è neanche un aspirapolvere sicuro
stavolta mi sa che devo affittare una
cantina per sta roba perché le norme
abbiamo e un cadavere imbustato non
ragazzi che allora c'è la moto di batman
che va bene meravigliosa ma questo
questo questo epico pupazzetto di
vendetta super sayan mi mancava
veramente grafico 9 questo qua veramente
fantastico grazie di cuore anche a te
verde getta perché stupendo e di
ripassare vedere che il diavolo è sta
roba è il questo fantastico parco
ragazzi ho trovato una scatola di tic
tac vuota fantastico anche quest'anno
sempre desiderata
grazie mille dopodiché ragazzi un
braccialetto di quelli che devi ischia
farti sul braccio tipo così mi sono
fatto malissimo e quindi ragazzi direi
che possiamo passare al fa vi risponde
la prima domanda arriva da michele
cataldi fare risponde favi fai un trucco
di magia
allora ragazzi adesso vi darò
dimostrazione nella tecnica di
duplicazione ed è una magia che conosco
soltanto io che posso fare con questa
vena fantastica evitano adesso la
dimostrazione pratica
habemus dop jones forse
parteciperò habemus doppio donna habemus
doppioni che sto giocando testa di
minchia federico effetti fa vi risponde
vuoi mi sapresti dire perché le civette
fanno l'amore con la figlia del dottore
è perché è la figlia del dottore [ __ ]
evitare l'anno fa vi risponde favi
sapresti piegare un foglio su se stesso
sette volte non so che cosa c'è di
strano sta domanda ma può comunque 12
volt è perfetto 3 4 5 6 7 6 ma
[ __ ] 666 e mezzo dai ragazzi direi
che possiamo concludere qui con le
domande è comunque la cosa che volevo
dire fatemi sapere per il contest e le
magliette se volete che lo faccia in
futuro e niente ragazzi come al solito
se vi do è piaciuto lasciate un commento
mi piace anche a pacelli facebook e con
nani video trovate nella descrizione
sensi dove rischi discrete vini ci
rivediamo prossimo video ragazzi